[Música]
el líder de la oposición boliviana y
gobernador de Santa Cruz Luis Fernando
Camacho fue detenido este miércoles la
fiscalía general del país señaló en su
comunicado que la detención está
relacionada con el proceso golpe de
estado 1 derivado de la crisis
sociopolítica que terminó con la salida
de Evo Morales del poder en 2019
el continente americano toma
precauciones ante el brote de Kobe 19
que golpea a China Estados Unidos
anunció que desde el 5 de enero exigirá
test covid a Los viajeros procedentes
del país asiático mientras chile amplió
la emergencia sanitaria hasta marzo de
2023 como medida preventiva ante el
escenario epidemiológico chino
la histórica tormenta invernal que dejó
más de 60 fallecidos en Estados Unidos
se cebo Especialmente con la Ciudad de
Búfalo en donde contaron hasta 34
muertes allí las tareas se centran ahora
en limpiar las calles y Buscar la
normalidad
Bienvenidos a Nueva informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Bolivia la fiscalía ordenó allí la
detención del gobernador de Santa Cruz
motor económico del país y uno de los
bastiones opositores en un comunicado se
señaló que se trata de un arresto que se
da en el marco del proceso denominado
golpe de estado 1 derivado de la crisis
sociopolítica que terminó con la salida
de Evo Morales del poder en 2019 Los
partidarios de Camacho califican la
detención como secuestro
Allá está el helicóptero una captura en
vivo así narraba desde un aeropuerto el
senador Eric Morón la detención de Luis
Fernando Camacho gobernador de la región
de Santa Cruz fue aprendido por el caso
golpe de estado 1 y lo anunció la
fiscalía en Twitter La decisión fiscal
no se trata de un secuestro o
persecución política por el contrario
fue emitida en el mes de octubre de la
presente gestión y cuenta con control
jurisdiccional del juez decimo de
instrucción en lo penal del tribunal
departamental de justicia de la paz Los
partidarios de Luis Fernando Camacho
bloquearon dos aeropuertos y calificaron
la detención de secuestro ya que
aseguran que no había situación para el
dirigente y que se le capturó con
violencia la información confirmada es
que los secuestraron en las proximidades
de su domicilio donde fue
interceptado por vehículos donde
hicieron uso de armas de fuego para
encañonar a las personas que lo
acompañaban y lo trasladaron con destino
a este aeropuerto de viruiro de ahí en
más no podemos establecer con precisión
paradero Santa Cruz es la mayor y más
rica región de Bolivia está gobernada
por el tercer partido más representado
en la asamblea nacional sobre Luis
Fernando Camacho pesa la acusación de
terrorismo por los hechos sucedidos en
2019 después de las elecciones en las
que habría ganado el expresidente Evo
Morales surgieron protestas con
Epicentro en la misma Santa Cruz que
terminaron con la renuncia de morales y
su salida del país además de 37 muertos
en las calles por ese mismo proceso
también está acusada la expresidenta
interina Yanina áñez quien ya fue
condenada a 10 años de prisión por el
caso golpe de estado dos
nos vamos hasta Argentina las abuelas de
la Plaza de Mayo que llevan 45 años
buscando a los niños robados ilegalmente
durante la dictadura anunciaron la
identificación del Nieto número 132 el
segundo en una semana Luego que el
pasado jueves anunciaran la
identificación del 131 tres años y medio
después de la la última identificación
el nieto 132 había iniciado la búsqueda
de su identidad en el año 2004 y ahora
se sabe que es hijo de una mujer
detenida y desaparecida en el año 1976 y
de un hombre sin identificar
y decenas de migrantes que pretendían
cruzar hacia Estados Unidos reaccionaron
reaccionaron luego de que la Corte
Suprema extendiera la normativa conocida
como título 42 emitida desde el comienzo
de la pandemia de Kobe 19 y que permite
expulsar del país a quienes entran y
regularmente por motivos de salud
pública
la incertidumbre colma la escena en la
frontera entre México y Estados Unidos
la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
prorrogar el título 42 la orden de
emergencia de Lara Trump que permite
expulsar a los migrantes por razones
sanitarias preocupa a las personas que
pretendían cruzar el paso fronterizo
hacia Estados Unidos
y la verdad Nos cae como
grande y ahora nos dicen de que no de
que lo alargaron más el artículo 42 y ya
no sabemos qué hacer sin embargo esta
extensión pedida por los estados
controlados por republicanos y que
durará al menos hasta finales de junio
no derrumba las esperanzas de los
migrantes yo salí de mi país con la
intención de cruzar de llegar los
Estados Unidos y yo todavía no me daba
por vencido yo voy a seguir mi rumbo así
sabe quedarme aquí en México
o
pasapa para aquel lado pero mi sueño es
cruza para aquel lado tengo temor de
cruzar así negar porque me da temor que
me que me agarren me atrapen y me
devuelvan y
aparece en el sistema ya no pueda
ingresar a Estados Unidos Entonces
quiero esperar mejor porque yo tengo la
fe y la esperanza que sí van a dar una
noticia y bueno y esperaré la medida de
la Corte Suprema que cuenta con marcada
mayoría conservadora fue criticada el
martes por el presidente Joe biden quien
la calificó como pero reconoció que
deberán hacerla cumplir mientras que la
suerte de miles de migrantes queda la
deriva en territorio mexicano
a partir del 5 de enero Estados Unidos
impondrá a pruebas obligatorias de Kobe
19 a Los viajeros provenientes de China
se une sí a otras naciones como India
Italia Japón y Taiwán que anunciaron la
medida después de que Beijing comenzara
a levantar sus estrictas políticas de
cero covid después de semanas de
manifestaciones desde el comienzo de la
pandemia china se ha enfrentado a
críticas internacionales sobre sus datos
oficiales del virus que muchos
consideran inconsistentes con la escala
del brote
con motivo de esta alza de los contagios
en China el Ministerio de salud de chile
señaló también este miércoles que la
alerta sanitaria instaurada desde el
inicio de la pandemia se mantendrá hasta
marzo de 2023 nuestra corresponsal en
Santiago Patricia Luna nos trae los
detalles
la ministra de salud chilena Jimena
Aguilera anunció este miércoles la
extensión de la alerta sanitaria que
rige en Chile hasta marzo de 2023 esto
ante la incertidumbre que genera la
situación epidemiológica sobre la covid
que se vive en este momento en China y a
la que ha hecho referencia la
Organización Mundial de la Salud al
Mostrar su preocupación por el
incremento significativo de cuadros
graves Esto hace que se mantenga esta
situación de alerta por ver qué es lo
que pudiera pasar Aunque a la ciudadanía
en este momento la covid no es una de
las cuestiones que más le preocupe están
agobiados por temas como la inflación o
los problemas de seguridad que se viven
en el país en la última jornada se
registraban un total de 5.000 casos
positivos y una positividad bastante
alta un 18,75% a nivel nacional que era
superado en 19% en el caso de la región
metropolitana el incremento de casos ha
ascendido un 15% en las últimas dos
semanas y un 12% en la última semana
mientras que las regiones del país que
tienen una tasa de incidencia por
100.000 habitantes más altas están todas
al norte arica y parignacota atacama
antofagasta y calama esto en un contexto
total en el que más de 5 millones de
chilenos de los 19 que existen en el
país se han contagiado y en el que el
número de fallecidos supera a las 63.000
personas un momento en el que en chile
no se ven mascarillas en la calle ya no
es obligatorio y solo continúa siendo
obligatorio llevar mascarilla en
recintos médicos y hospitalarios
este fin de semana se ha vivido la peor
tormenta invernal de los últimos 50 años
en Estados Unidos con al menos 34
muertos de los más de 60 que se han
registrado en todo el país la ciudad de
búfalos se ha llevado la peor parte del
temporal ahí aún buscan supervivientes
una postal navideña en forma de 140
centímetros de nieve en Búfalo este
miércoles la segunda ciudad más grande
del estado de Nueva York despertó bañada
por el blanco tras una tormenta que dejó
decenas de Muertos durante el fin de
semana Y puso los termómetros con grados
a bajo cero
durante la tormenta Fue bastante
horrible el viento aullaba y la nieve
iba a la deriva
Hay algún supermercado abierto pero
están teniendo dificultades para
abastecerse hay algo de pan pero se han
quedado sin leche y sin huevos
[Música]
y es que esta es la mayor tormenta que
ha registrado Estados Unidos en los
últimos 50 años ante su ferocidad muchos
intentaron huir quedaron atrapados en
sus autos y murieron congelados sin
posibilidad de acceso para los equipos
de rescate razón a por la que el
gobierno local ha prohibido conducir y
está intentando restablecer el
suministro eléctrico y despejar las
carreteras
Aunque Hemos limpiado alrededor del 70%
de las calles de la Ciudad de Búfalo
después de esta tormenta histórica
nuestra flota de nieve junto a otros
equipos continúan su trabajo de despejar
la ciudad
lejos de un cuento de Navidad este
fenómeno extremo ha hecho de estas las
peores navidades para muchas familias en
el país con al menos uno coma siete
millones de personas afectadas por los
cortes de Electricidad y cientos de
carreteras bloqueadas y vuelos
cancelados hasta aquí las noticias sigan
con nuestra programación
[Música]